what happened to The Flash 55 million
opening weekend domestically about 130
million worldwide this was supposed to
be the greatest comic book movie of all
time according to James Gunn and David
zazlab Tom Cruise liked it Stephen King
the novelist liked it but why didn't the
audiences gravitate towards the flash
now I actually watched this movie and I
left my uh you know out of the theater
reaction you can see that here on the
channel wow here and I liked the movie I
thought it was fun man I enjoyed seeing
Michael Keaton back as Batman I thought
Sasha kaye's Supergirl was great and I
thought Ezra Miller did a tremendous job
at performing two different Barry
Allen's and the Flash in this film
performance wise is they were all
awesome
but what was the reason people were not
going to see The Flash well I have some
thoughts on this and I thought let's
share them and let's hear from you guys
as well in the comment section below
okay first and foremost we just saw nine
seasons of The Flash on TV that's right
nine Seasons Grant Gustin was playing
the the title role did a great job I
actually liked his version of The Flash
probably even Better Than Ezra Miller's
in terms of characterization of The
Flash
but you've seen pretty much the same
storyline that you're seeing in this
movie right now minus of course Batman
and Supergirl play out
in the TV series during the height of
its popularity
and with the last couple years of us
being indoors a lot of people couldn't
go to the movie theaters because they
weren't open so what did they do they
started streaming content and you're
gonna start streaming TV series so I'm
sure the flash since it has a lot of
Seasons under its belt got a lot of
streaming numbers out of there which
means ending the ninth season this year
actually a couple months ago now you're
introducing The Flash movie
with pretty much the same storyline as
you saw in the TV show
why would I want to spend a lot of my
hard-earned money take my family to a
movie that's going to replicate what I
just saw at home
that's one
uh one point Food For Thought another
Point Ezra Miller now let's not talk
about their issues outside of their
acting which of course there's a lot of
legal troubles happening
and um it's going to be very very
challenging for them to get out of it
but I'm gonna go beyond that I'm gonna
go on a limb and say something that may
be a little bit controversial but I just
didn't like Ezra Miller as the flash I
didn't they're a fantastic performer a
great actor they did a great job in this
film
um portraying two different Barry
Allen's from two different times lines
and I mean it was
a beautiful performance but I just don't
see his characterization as the flash as
the flash that I gravitate towards to
and I don't think a lot of the audience
does either now it kind of worked in the
Snyder verse in the sense that the flash
was always a sort of a supporting
character one-liner is a little bit
quirky a little bit of an odd ball but
it sort of worked within the um the
various different characters that Zack
Snyder kind of brought together
but as a lead of a film are we really
interested in the flash
did Ezra's performance as the flash
through the Snyder verse to this point
did it make us excited to see
a title film with this character
I don't think so I really don't I mean I
was watching and I was like
yeah you know it's good a performance as
this was
there's no chemistry between him and
Iris West whatsoever zero
it's almost like they were acting on two
different days and they just kind of cut
the scenes together it was like
oh man this really doesn't work at all
while the quirkiness works to some
degree you want to see a commonality in
Your Heroes via that it's Captain
America or if it's Batman or if it's
Superman or if it's
somebody else there has to be this part
of the character where you go okay I am
on the journey with this person they're
my hero they are going to take us
through this journey and we know we're
going to be okay we would love to see
them fail and fall but we know we're
gonna be okay and there's that
confidence and I just don't feel that we
have that confidence in the flash as
he's being portrayed right now through
the characterization of Ezra Miller and
that's just a point that I have you may
disagree with me I'd love to hear from
you guys in the comment section below by
the way if you'd like to subscribe to
the channel right now hit that like
button as well more content coming your
way also another Point here no Superman
look people like Superman and they want
to see Superman used correctly and if
Superman would have been in this film
you can keep Supergirl in there as well
I think Sasha Kai as I mentioned before
did a fantastic job I think she's great
at in the role and hopefully she does
more Supergirl in the future
Superman would have been a great mentor
to Barry and it also would have brought
the audiences in because for the last
number of DC movies we get hints of
Superman we get chatter about him we get
a cameo scene at the very end of the
Black Adam but we never get to see
Superman as Superman for how many years
and he is the DC he is the ultimate
comic book hero and if you don't utilize
him in a film like this where you need
that gravitas
you're missing out and I would I I would
bet you right now if Henry Cavill was in
this film as one of the top three build
actors in it it would have done a lot
better all right and before we go to my
next Point here's a quick message from
our sponsor if you're looking for a
laptop that has both power and
possibility look no further than the
Asus Zenbook 14x OLED it features a
large 70 watt hour battery and stunning
Nano H 14.5 inch 2.8 K 120 hertz OLED
display powered by the latest 13th gen
in Toco I9 CPU and RTX 3050 GPU all
packed in a thin 16.9 mm chassis that
only weighs 1.5 kilograms so you can
stay focused at work or play for more
information check out asus.com
also another Point here Michael Keaton
as Batman is great yeah
[Music]
I'm Batman but for the younger
generation out there they have not seen
the 89 Batman movies they probably saw
George Clooney and Val Kilmer and then
of course you know uh Christian Bale
The Dark Knight and then now Ben Affleck
and we're going with Robert Patterson
but they've never seen the 89 movie so
to relate to that Batman maybe a little
bit far-fetched but again you're not
going to get Christian Bell into
something like this so well there you
have it okay another Factor
the James Gunn announcement
that killed the DCU man that killed all
these films I mean I get why they wanted
to make the announcement gonna take over
the the DC portion of Warner Brothers
properties and they're going to you know
revamp it
but the moment that he made that
announcement
you could pretty much kiss all the box
office numbers on these movies goodbye
that's it and I'm sure Warner Brothers
looking back on it now looking at the
books going maybe we should have waited
for this announcement and I personally
would have waited because I love gun and
I can't wait to see what he does with
this with Superman and what he does with
the DCU because I think he's going to
bring a lot of cool things to it
but I think that announcement was a bit
too premature I know the fans wanted to
hear it I know that The Insider the the
trade the Insiders the trade you know
all the Publications they wanted to hear
what's going on what are they going to
do with the movie who's going to stay
who's gonna go
but I think they should have stopped the
announcement and I don't think they
should have said that nobody's going to
be who or this or that and let the
cameos or whatever was going to be the
film be in the film and then at the very
end when Aquaman ends this run they can
come in and say look we're going to
start as a clean fresh slate these are
gonna be the actors who are playing
these characters this is the tone we're
going for this is the vibe we're going
for and then it feels as an audience
you're on board right now you look
through Facebook comments they're like
who's who who's playing Wonder Woman
what's going on with Superman what's
going on with Batman who's Batman what's
the people are confused
and I think that confusion means people
aren't going to spend their money and
one final thought here because it's
something that people don't really talk
about that much online look through the
past couple years we have not been able
to go to a movie theater right I mean
last year was kind of the first time we
could sort of do that and so in a safe
capacity
so between 2020 and you could say 2022
the beginning of it people were buying
technology TVs computers laptops they
were getting into streaming more because
that's the only entertainment they could
get and so now much like how when the
digital music came into play where you
could either buy a song or buy an album
you're now seeing that happen to film
people are going to watch how much they
spend in terms of films if it's a film
that they feel is worthy of spending
that 50 to 100 US dollars to go with
their family to a theater they'll do it
but if they can say hey wait a second I
can wait 30 days and watch this on
streaming
I don't need to see it I'll watch it on
streaming and I think you're seeing that
happen so with these superhero films if
everything is saving the universe saving
the universe saving the universe and the
Multiverse and the Multiverse and the
Multiverse which is very confusing
audience is like wait a second I'm just
gonna watch it at home it'll save me
money and if the movie's not good it's
okay I only spent a couple of hours of
my time but if the movie's not good I've
not only spent a lot of my hard-earned
money due to inflation right now which
is you know everybody's tidying up their
wallets but at the same time I lost two
to three hours
so there needs to be an adjustment in
terms of how we view content how we look
at the box office and I think that's
you're seeing that happen that's coming
into play anyway guys those are my
thoughts on the flash why I didn't do so
well at the box office let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below do
you agree with me do you disagree with
me do you have anything to add would
love to hear from you guys once again
subscribe to us helps us out a lot take
care stay safe and I will chat to you
soon bye